we've got bachelorettes I don't love the
term sister eyes we've got bad boys back
in town
guys like that should get beat up and
we've got Chris Harrison on a bus
welcome to the first ever bachelor
nation bus tour this is the Bachelorette
15th reunion special and it's time for
roses and rose hey you guys hi it's me
Lauren Zima and there's only one of me
but there were 15 13 of the
bachelorettes from our favorite show
back together for ABC's Bachelorette
season 15 reunion special oh and what a
special it was I really enjoyed it you
guys what did you think of the reunion
special was the reunion special
everything you wanted it to be was it
special did you feel reunited and let me
tell you it was dirty and reunions aside
we also got some reveals ooh drink for a
reveal oh so here's the fun little
secret from fantasy suites the night
that Garret and I spent the night
together
we may have broken the bed sorry mom I
got a big glass today I'm getting right
into it because after last week's
episode I did get some feedback that you
guys thought it was a little too
gameofthrones focused and I'm sorry I
apologize I had a minor detour of an
obsession from my bachelor bachelorette
obsession to Game of Thrones but I can't
apologize for loving Game of Thrones but
I'm sorry for bringing that content here
to all the people who had a problem with
it please still love me I love just like
Jorah wanted the love of a no I'm done
no more I'm done I promise anyway I
promise on that nope I don't I will I
will take an oath okay
so you guys Chris Harrison is on a
Bachelor but honestly cheers to this he
could not be more in his element for the
entirety of this special longtime host
Chris Harrison is on a very long
double-decker bus surrounded by fans
getting to hosts getting to speak to the
people being the center of attention he
is loving it and we are loving it we
hope he doesn't fall off he's standing
on this moving bus a double-decker I was
worried drink if you were worried mmm
but sources couldn't perfect it still of
life okay
that's dark okay so we are using this
bus tour to relive moments in bachelor
and bachelorette show history and I was
surprised this episode was not just a
Bachelorette moment special there's some
bachelor stuff in there too but anyways
we're using this bus tour to go all
around Los Angeles reliving great
moments in the franchise locations of
dates and all the times we threw people
off of buildings yes we're looking back
at you know Ali and Roberto they shared
their first kiss
it's nearly falling to their deaths and
Sean and Sarah basically falling to
their death they did a freefall 360 feet
I'm just glad that Chris Harrison didn't
fall to his death cheers everybody
cheers for every time someone fell in
love off the building into the darkness
all right and also drink every time that
we're reliving a moment where the show
made tone-deaf people sing
[Music]
[Applause]
all my love to Becca kufran but you
weren't hitting those notes babe I love
you I don't know if I could have done
better but you did not do great okay
cheers to Becca
now cheers to the fans on this bus these
are some serious stands that they found
this wasn't just any old nobody who
buddy who are you people pop it around
on the street these are some bachelor
beat by boobers around I don't know how
they vetted these people but these
people knew what was up I mean they are
kissing each other they are in love
they're in love with the show the girl
in the front was getting chills like
calm town it's Los Angeles it's very
sunny here you're not cold it's gonna be
okay it's just a bus oh and you know I
wondered today to fulfill any of their
bachelor bachelorette dreams would one
of them be dropped off a building of
some kind turns out now spoiler alert on
the episode oh and this is the guy we
held the date with next but speaking of
falling [ __ ] by all is here Nick is
shocker at the top of a building to meet
these people and a drink every time we
make a joke about how single Nick is
have you watched any of my seasons
[Music]
that's that's one way to not get a rose
well you have a boyfriend - OH
are you here for the right reasons it
doesn't feel good are you looking for a
good girlfriend away I mean really
anything at this point maybe okay what
happened to you a lot lots of jokes lots
of notes tone-deaf and blackout drunk
yeah please drink responsibly and please
fall into relationships responsibly a
message from NIC violet Co we love you
Nick I do love Nick so man Instagram was
saying like why is anybody ever taking
love advice from Nick I don't say
experience teaches lessons but Nick I
want an experience I would take Nick's
advice over a whole lot of other people
who are out there giving advice anyway
side notes sidetrack for get it out of
here we don't like it the people don't
like it don't talk about girls don't
talk about Avon all right can I talk
about shallow
is that still okay I love that song you
guys please don't make me forget
everything I love I love you I love
taste see here I love G ot I'm done that
nope okay so we are now catching up with
some former bachelorettes finally since
that was the whole reason we off tuned
in we've got there
we're on the bus still but we're also
getting to the bachelorettes and Kaitlyn
Bristowe is talking about how dramatic
her season was my season just seemed to
be a controversial season it was fun but
challenging
I love Kaitlyn for her honesty she
remembers you know made some mistakes
did some things it was a great season
honestly might be my favorite
bachelorettes season of all time I'm
gonna say it just in terms of all the
elements the lead the contestants the
drama what happened where's your
favorite Bachelorette of all time what
do you guys think what is your favorite
bachelor out of all time so far let me
know and Kaitlyn also really talking
about her new relationship with Jason
quite a lot this gave some seriousness
to the relationship to me I mean I've
hung out with the two of them together
they seemed very happy and very into
each other but the fact that she was
talking about it on TV on the special
give it some gravitas what did you guys
think how serious is this for Kaitlyn
and Jason I love them together two smart
people good-looking people having fun
drinking wine I take it it's very
on-brand for me and for them and I had
to enjoy it oh I chose to reach out to
Becca before and make sure it was okay
because I'm a big bet that guy and I'm a
classy lady okay then we caught up with
Deanna Pappas Pappas Tagliani ofegli ah
no baloney A's da Vinci's Sistine Chapel
ceiling Greek name lady
I love Dianna she just has so many names
and they're all difficult to say and
spell but I adore her she seems very
sweet I've interviewed her before all my
love and you know what she reminded us
that her relationship came not from her
season but from meaning someone threw
bachelor nation the show ultimately led
me to Stephen just like kayln and and
Dianna is now married to a Steven
and they have kids and that's great and
so cheers to bachelor world for not
necessarily finding you love on the show
but finding you love in another way
Cheers mmm okay and there are a lot of
successful relationships for the
bachelorettes we got to give them
applause I think overall Bachelorette
success rate is higher the bachelor
success rate cheers to the ladies girls
who run the world
[Music]
god this is good rose' today I'm
actually wearing the color of what kind
of probably my favorite Rose a would
borderline be on my very first night
being Bachelorette I told Chris Harrison
that I wanted a minivan full of kids and
Here I am I also wrote down let's drink
for every one of Emily maynard's kids
she has so many I couldn't even count
him they were all running around and
then she says she wants one more crazy
enough I think I want like one more she
you go girl
what a woman I can't even I've killed so
many plants you guys I don't know how I
would do cheers to Emily Maynard okay we
are back on the bus and Chris Harrison
is running to Neil Lane why was he
worried he would jump over a fence this
but you know we didn't see Chris
Harrison run for so many of these years
of the show Thomas um he's running all
the time
[Music]
and I don't know why we have to pretend
that Neil Lane didn't know he was coming
bus full of bachelor nation fans they're
gonna freak out when they see you can
you come join us for a second yes your
honor
Chris runs up to me Alain and he says
hey man would you mind coming out for
this tour it's like Neil you knew you
were coming
Neil's probably not in that store every
day Neil wasn't where and we're all okay
with it tear down that fourth wall in
those moments all right it's all about
love
look at you in tears now you got him in
tears and now back to the girl at the
front she had chills and now she's in
tears
patrick burus she okay can someone get
her some wine I'm worried about this
girl but cheers to the producers for
finding her in this crowd of fans and
putting her right at the front that's
they have those instincts about drama
you know they were like put this girl at
the front freak out cheers mm-hmm you
don't want somebody boring at the front
in your car or in life I don't know what
that meant
take it or leave it how you will advice
for me and Nick vile we're both okay at
it okay and now oh my god you guys the
show built in a drinking game for us and
I want to say please drink responsibly
responsibly drink for every first that
they list I don't even have them all
here but they gave us the first kiss the
first rose the first time the wrong name
was said the first hot tub the first
skinny dip the first man cried the first
man sob drink responsibly and I
definitely can't wait to talk to you
more inside
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
and again they were doing bachelor and
bachelorette so that was quite a lot of
first I also want to know you know how
did the research and confirm all that
because it shows but not a long time
we're pas just watching hours and hours
of footage in like a dark room somewhere
or did they have some kind of like
bachelor bachelorette like file system
with like all the notes from all the
seasons of it would look like this okay
we're back from that sidetrack I know we
don't always love a sidetrack
sometimes we run here things can go off
the rails and get crazy drink for big
Polly big Polly getting a little camera
moment I love that for him longtime
security guy on the show loved by all
big Polly with a big heart cheered and
over the years there have been quite a
few other bad boys come on The
Bachelorette stir things up now we are
catching up with some former bad boys of
the Bachelorette and this felt so
satisfying to me because remember we had
done a roses in rows a when we went back
through the 15 most dramatic moments in
Bachelorette history watch it if you
haven't shameless plug and many of these
bad boys were in those clips and now the
show went and found them so we get was
the guy who had a girlfriend on Jillian
Harris that sees it the first guy ever
on The Bachelor to make it to the top
four
with a girlfriend and it turns out that
West the country singer with a
girlfriend is you having longer hair now
and having more tattoos now great it's
not great but he has a construction
company so that could be better okay and
Wes says that he has learned that life
you have a tendency to be humbled by
life then we get Justin rated-r from Ali
Fedotowsky season of the bringer of one
of my favorite moments in Bachelorette
history you guys when he was as we did
in that 15 most dramatic moments video
Seamus thought he was walking to get
away from Ali Fedotowsky it's such a
great moment but anyway Justin rated-r
is now Justin rated by majority of my
time goes into bartending he's a
bartender no noble profession I'm a big
fan make me a good drink I don't
appreciate you but yeah you know it's
interesting he still seems very
confident and he says quote I'm gonna
say the girls definitely love rated R
you might want to graduate the word
girls to the word women just a
suggestion
oh this moment he cheers to the good old
days and that was dark one of the guys
in the house referred to Ricki as
baggage and then Kaylin from Emily
Maynard season the one who said her
daughter was baggage and she told him
that got me out
get the out in an iconic moment he is
now in love with golf and his dog got it
two thing is that I have not aborted
with guys like that should get beat up
but there's David I don't remember him
at all
but David was bad and now David's
married and David's glad no he's not now
he's crying yeah bad boy right why is he
crying oh wow I'm not judging the crying
but all of these moments are very dark
aren't they this is where it all starts
now the fans are in the mansion so
exciting I've been there you guys
someone really lives there it's a house
it's great but the fans are in the
mansion so exciting so exciting in fact
that one woman asks if a jar of cookies
is real lady what are you on yes it's
real it's there this is real this is
real it's all real what did you take
before this bus ride and how much fun
did whatever you took make the bus ride
what in the fresh hell is fresh candy
candy is not fresh it is very processed
are you all right James to you and the
fans no wait not cheers I won the Terry
girl is now sobbing and someone else is
kissing the driveway don't kiss the
driveway I know they hose it down but
it's not clean get a hold of yourselves
I need more wine for this these people I
love them I love bachelor nation I love
fancy guys honestly the bus ride thing
sounds fun I wish I was on it I'm glad
Chris Harrison didn't fall off of it
it's all good I'm just saying that it's
I'm just let's just all stay grounded
okay the cookie jar is real tangible
things are real we're all here
right aren't we oh god okay I'm good now
speaking of real the real love of Rachel
Lindsay and Bryan a basilica hold his
name last name it's hard to remember
Abba solo but they are really in love
and they talk about how they are going
to get married this August that is so
awesome we've been waiting for this for
Rachel I adore Rachel so happy for them
honestly great good things and they get
a little moment on this episode which I
appreciate good give them some time they
are picking out wedding rings with me
Elaine and that is so great
and I am a bit confused on what's
happening after that I think three
John's having to see kind of a bridal
shower which is wearing a fascinator and
a tank top
looking great no matter what she's
wearing nobody else is wearing a
fascinator got my closest girlfriends
here it says that she's with some of her
closest girlfriends and some of those
women like Astrid like I know those are
her friends I didn't know where an Ali
Fedotowsky were that close but you know
what if there's one thing that can bring
people together its cake and cocktails
anytime cake and cocktails are at an
event I will show up
thank you I'll show up I'll make a new
friend I don't even need both I need one
or the other is there cake they're great
today is the first time I am meeting
Emily and we have a very strange
connection Emily and then the women are
talking about all of their mutual dating
weirdness I don't love the terms sister
wives but there are some sort of weird
connections the only person connection I
have is you and Jake and Jake cuz I got
strong tongue kisser tunics one guy was
on multiple seasons and some of them
have dated a lot of them have dated the
same guys in different capacities and
scenarios and situations so who do you
share if somebody was Emily it's a group
of women who have dated many of the same
men and Ali Fedotowsky on this episode
called the bachelorettes The Sisterhood
and I agree it is a sisterhood it's also
a bit of an Eskimo sisterhood and that's
okay
after we finished night one I'm going
back to the hotel where I'm staying and
I'm going up the stairs and I just start
projectile vomiting drink every time Joe
Joe Fletcher had an unexpected vomit
story you see this coming she had
multiple or were they the same I
couldn't tell she was just retelling the
same story and let me tell you it was
dirty
Joe just kept talking about throwing up
she's so beautiful it's so fun and weird
and jarring to see someone who's so
beautiful just talk about spewing
honestly I don't think I've ever told
anybody this but after Roberto and I
broke up I actually went on a date with
Frank and we were a romantic for like a
night they had these little moments
where the match starts for revealing
secrets and Ali Fedotowsky revealed that
she hooked up with Frank after she broke
up with Roberto that was huge that was
big because when I watched that season I
remember thinking that Ali just loved
Frank so much and Frank's self exited to
go be with Nicole question mark I don't
think he's still with that person and
Wow then herberto were together for a
while then they broke up and then she
had a night with Frank I love this this
is the stuff of romance novels I am here
for this I wish that that had been all
filmed not the not the night but who is
Hannah really what is this unique woman
really like Chris Harrison is now in
Alabama he survived the bus so exciting
he's in Tuscaloosa that's a fun word to
say Tuscaloosa Tuscaloosa I've had not
allowed to eat today you guys and I got
smart
I'm also ill summer on a variety of meds
don't tell my doctor this okay yes
enough questions about night health
choices bris is touring Hannah's house
and by touring I mean going through her
house when she's not around I mean this
was a setup but honestly it was fun
that's Joey Fatone I did not know her
dad was a Backstreet Boy Chris Harris is
a funny guy guys he just is I've always
thought this and I wish we got more
moments like this from him on the show
shoot going through Anna's room look at
that sign she had it says something like
be still and know or something I don't
know I'm here for what people have
printed signs of words because it just
really says a lot about them he went in
her nightstand drawer $5 take that
that's a bold choice to go in a woman's
nightstand drawer that was bold and I
would have said get out of there okay
very personal and then Chris and Hannah
are touring not her home but her town
and I don't know there's old ladies who
we meet but she tells Hannah to be
choice see I love that and then we meet
Hannah's family and Hannah's dad is a
barber and he's got beautiful long hair
and he calls himself Robby Oh like Fabio
and I adore him and he cuts Chris
Harrison's hair and he doesn't give him
a shave and I'm glad because I love
stubble what he's doing stubble beard
clean-shaven I'm here first level out of
myself I'm doing this oh my god then I'm
ending it there I don't remember what
else happened on the rest of this
episode except that we got new scenes
from Hannah's season a preview of what's
to come and this trailer actually said a
lot so let's buckle in well we got all
kinds of naked and some kind of S&M AHA
Rin a situation what and whoa
Vienna feels like the guys aren't asking
her about herself none
know anything about me dang I have to
say you guys sounds like Hannah might
have a crop of guys who are really into
themselves also head DJ online calm
because I talked to Chris Harrison about
the scoop of man he said there's a lot
of man drama this season and whoa we are
learning a lot about potentially what
guys make it pretty far because one guy
who looks like he might be one of the
Peters I don't know it's hard to tell
because they're pictures that were
released were so rough but he says he's
falling for Hannah I really am falling
for you which could indicate that he's
around for a minute and then jedd that's
definitely the guy Jed I can tell that
just from the pictures I don't want to
hold back anymore he's definitely around
for a minute and then Hannah we 0
telling someone she's falling in love
with them and then the men are fighting
a legend dropping a lot of f-bombs as
always had a talk with my god what be
[Music]
and whoa we have a lot to take in about
Luke P the other manner calling him
violet avoids an aggressive you're
aggressive you are a psychopath
and we heard he was screaming at someone
and then Tyler wants to be Hannah's guy
but then Hanna talks to Luke about being
her guy and he says he doesn't know if
he can go all-in
I don't know whoa whoa Wow Wow
I am so excited for this season so
excited what did you actually get the
Bachelorette reunion special was it
everything you wanted did you have more
questions that it didn't answer what
else do you want to know because I could
find out the answers for some of your
questions if you want to know even the
comments below
let's bring jcn because we are now less
than one week away from the premiere of
Hannah Brown season of The Bachelorette
and we have seen a fair amount of
footage from the new season at this
point and so I want to do some
prediction Wow so dapper a man bun last
week but full flow this week okay my
friend
so tell me seeing what you've seen
knowing what you know what do you think
we will get out of this season of The
Bachelorette the 15th hmm Wow well
Hannah be at the beginning might be a
bit awkward might not say anything aside
from roll tide but towards the end she
will be her hand a beast
Hannah be regal that's right Queen that
we all know she can be and she will take
the day Wow
take the day that's like something they
would say on a show that I won't mention
because people get upset if I do so JC I
love what you just said and I am with
you on that this is gonna be a great
season I actually can't tell at this
point after my interview with Chris
ahead TT my calm I can't tell who's
gonna bring it more Hanna or the men but
I do think that Hanna is going to be
incredibly raw authentic real strips
down I've interviewed her several times
at this point you guys and booboo says
what she thinks and I appreciate that
because that makes for the best reality
TV say what you think on who you are
Hanna does both of those can't wait to
watch the premiere is May 13th on ABC
and we will of course be recapping it
and posting
roses and roses the morning after we
love you guys so much you don't have any
wine
why don't you cheers of this fake plant
I don't have real plants here because I
kill them